[Music]
last year I collaborated with the UN to
visualize their annual emissions gap
report which as you hopefully know
highlights the difference between all we
need to do and what we're actually doing
to prevent dangerous levels of climate
change one of the key points in the
report was that to keep global warming
below two degrees greenhouse gas
emissions will have to pick by 2020 and
then decree is rapidly afterwards but
understanding that not every country has
peaked once in red was not going to
happen in just one chart because the
emissions of China u.s. and India simply
dwarfs everyone else's so to make that
point we transition that visualization
so each country was a little square with
their own little chart inside arranged
in a world map so we can appreciate the
regional patterns those countries that
have yet to pick are the ones in in red
but not everyone is has the same
responsibilities it really just said
this some countries emissions are much
bigger right so here we transition the
cells again to show which countries
emissions and see the biggest
contributors you can barely see that
probably the next one you can see it
more clearly and then who is and who
isn't on track to meet their commitments
using storytelling breaking apart a
complicated data set visualizing it and
guiding it guiding people through it is
a very effective way of presenting
information but you can turn a
presentation of actual for abstract
forms into something epic
connecting with that the story that
story at an emotional level we can
understand those squiggly lines squiggly
lines and unevenly sized squares but we
cannot really connect with them I've
been lucky enough to have worked in some
of the most groundbreaking newsrooms in
the planet the New York Times was my
home for six years as it became the
digital powerhouse that it is today and
most recently I had the privilege to
lead the visual desk at the Guardian for
two years but you may sole mano who the
heck I am but you've probably seen this
and if you've not I am very disappointed
I created this set of slides to sort of
confess my sins as a data visualization
professional this was the first one and
it's a set of twelve I tried to
completely obliterate the meme by just
doing all the iterations that you could
possibly think of I in this twenty years
that I've been doing data driven and
visual storytelling I learned that to be
a I learned to be a data reporter and
that interesting things only appear when
we connect different data sets to bring
the right context for interpretation I
learned to use visual analysis and I
understood that it was key sometimes to
understand your data and I learned that
presenting it in a way that connects
with whomever reads or access that
information makes data visual stories
more memorable more helpful and more
actionable that's what I do I work to
communicate data in a tangible way and
an in a relatable way and my ultimate
ultimate goal is to put data in terms of
audiences can feel weaving narrative and
visual metaphors that reinforce the data
I come from a school of visual
journalism in Spain that does things
like this this by a Catalan visual
journalist at work in in Argentina for a
long time and this was made in the in
the 90s and this was like completely
groundbreaking for the way it thought of
presenting data in in a newspaper using
this using metaphors and it's it's funny
how we sometimes associate this kind of
visual more metaphorical more
illustrative visualizations with Spain
on one of my fav all-time favorites is a
piece that the New York Times did it's
like this is visualization that has a
power to move you this for some reason
is stuck with me like for forever this
is gun deaths by age group and the
colors mean homicide is gray suicide is
red and accident is yellow or golden and
that yeah somebody says wow it's kind of
yeah that's why they it became one night
when I saw it and when I thought about
it and when I when I realized that it
wasn't was not portraying that data in
in a poor way it was it was like it was
there was something powerful about those
are the killers those bullets are the
killers you're not showing the
silhouette of a person you're not you're
showing that you're doing a metaphor
you're asking people to do a little bit
of a jump before and once that jump
happens it sticks with you year and a
half ago I collaborated with The
Washington Post on a story debunking the
some of the arguments that gender pay
deniers use and the ones that they throw
around every time the issue comes up and
as the hook for the for the story which
actually determine when we were going to
publish it we we thought of when women
started working for free
it's not a something new it's not an
original idea in in 1975 in Iceland
women went on strike at to something
p.m. which was like the moment in the
day where they would start working for
free so we did we did that but for the
whole but whole for the whole year and
that means in in the u.s. that metaphor
of money as as time applied to to the US
fell around 80% of the so the the gender
gap is 80% the gap is 20 and in terms of
a year it's around October that's when
we published it so we created did that
for every profession in the in the
census like when did women started
working for free and you could type your
your profession and see when you started
to work for free and there was a lot of
I am NOT going to explain too much of
what we did in terms of data because is
very elementary for for all of you it
wasn't for for us what we try to what we
try to do but I can I can sort of show
you what my process is when
when I create this sort of data visual
essays it always starts with with the
data and that leads you to an analysis
and to structure things but one of the
key moments for me yes when you get to
the hook to the connection that you want
to the audience to remember what do you
want them to find memorable what do you
want them to recall when they go and
tell somebody else about your your story
and then the rest is pretty much those
those keys the analysis and finding the
right hook is what makes this sort of
this sort of stories unique the rest is
pretty much it's how we all construct
stories we find the structure we edited
with the sign it whatever but finding
the right analysis and finding the right
hook the right frame for this is is the
key I recommend you guys take a look at
it it's it's pretty interesting if you
google can we talk about the gender pay
gap Washington Post you'll you'll find
it and I use as well as metaphors I use
what I called emotional math when I was
at the Guardian we one of the recurring
themes of if you guys have if you
anybody from the UK here okay you know
how much well in Spain too but how much
home prices have raised so we wanted to
we had we had access to the every home
purchase since 1995 in England and Wales
because that's how the Office for
National Statistics in the UK works
England and Wales are packaged Scotland
in Northern Ireland are something else
so we can do it for the whole UK could
only do it for here and the data
by itself didn't reveal much but we were
doing we were doing some brainstorming
and I am very keen on shutting people up
when somebody who is an introvert starts
to talk and this was one of those
moments one of the one of the developers
of girl from a woman from Taiwan I'm
sorry a woman from Taiwan said well what
if and the moment she said what if like
I made everybody shut up and she came
with she came up with the idea whatever
we let people enter their their income
and because banks don't give you a
mortgage of more than four times your
4.5 your income you could see if you can
afford to live there or not because we
had historical data we could see when
you could actually have purchased a home
in that place you're looking at we
basically put it in terms that made it
relevant for you we showed you how
unaffordable the country had became for
you and all the sudden the visualization
was like personal it was your personal
story was your micro story in in this it
put the data in very real raw terms that
affected you and I try sometimes to come
up with inventive interfaces to get my
point across in 2015 one of the biggest
financial stories was how China's
slowdown could affect could wait on the
countries are dependent on exporting to
to China and we did a lot of number
crunching we did we found out that
putting it in context with other
datasets started to put data in terms
that were were
we're pattern started to to emerge and
one of the Cutler's a bunny one of the
developers in in our team put together
this this interactive prototype for the
reporters to understand what was
happening when with that uncertainty of
how much China's imports could go would
go down how much it weighed would it
wait on another in other countries but
when it came time to communicate that we
realized that letting the user drag
China's imports down with and on the
phone is really really ain't like
letting them drag it down with her thumb
you could see how how things came down
at a different pace how it weighed down
the other countries at a different pace
and it brought data to life in a in a
completely different way and that was at
the top and the rest was like breaking
down what those experts we're about and
I also use sense of humor when you can
to to play even more with those with
those metaphors humor we know it's more
memorable
even when you like put dark things
through through the humour filter we
tend to remember them more I am so I'm
terrible at fixing things I moved to
Girona two years ago and when when we
moved there I spent I think it was like
an unbearable amount of time googling
how to fix things around the house I'm a
complete disappointment for my
father-in-law
not true he loves me but every time I
need to fix something he's like really
so I pitched the story to Google Trends
and we did an interactive essay - about
things people search how to do and this
is one of the elements one of the at the
top the size of each element corresponds
to to the search volume and I don't know
with let me let me go back and then play
it again because somebody from Russia
here now Russians somebody from Eastern
Europe because the pattern is similar
what's up with fixing the you fix your
washing machines like you google how to
fix your washing machine I was
incredible and that was one of the
things that that immediately when when
people were using it they were
commenting on like wait what people use
said like search how to fix it washing
machine
sorry that's light I don't know what it
was doing there for the and to wrap that
up for the for the 2010 World
Environment Day the UN with him I
collaborate a lot they they're there
their theme was beating plastic
pollution and I work with them to create
an interactive and visual story that
summarized the UN plastic pollution
report and as the opener we showed the
geometric growth of plastic waste since
the 1950s in the form of this visual of
raining trash
basically transform the data in that
small chart there from an expert in
plastic pollution Jenna team back into
this visual of raining trash the rate of
falling trash is changes based on the on
the data in that decade and as I was
working on it my then four year old now
five walked into the room and said like
that why why is it raining more and more
trash he couldn't read and he didn't
have the tools to understand what was
happening he didn't have the context but
he could read what was happening because
we respond much more immediately when
things are presented to us in this like
raw terms when then when we guide
immediately people through lots of fun
nuance and details we can do it later we
can do it after we we engage them after
we connect with them we engage our
system first first system one first and
then we engage our system too because
it's not about the data the abstraction
of it but about the people another
moment with my with my four-year-old
I've used this light before and when I
was working on it and putting the this
Bart bar charts or histogram and the and
the people together he he tends to walk
in while I'm working
and I asked me what am i doing I'm Teddy
are you doing a graphic so I asked him
like what is more important this or this
it was like duh this one like why it was
like because it's people and taking all
that making date about people and hook
you emotionally and weaving a narrative
to explain the new ones is what we try
to do also for the UN for the 2017
environment assembly we start counting
the number of people that were dying
because of an unhealthy environment and
climate change the moment you open the
interactive and someone in western
Pacific is going to die in three two one
and we call to action later how do we
stop that to show you the details and
the new ones of this and the reasons and
in more data or we hook you first
emotionally and this is a project we did
here with karma bata who's in the
audience about gender violence violence
against women in in Catalunya
and one of the one of the things that we
realized when we were working on this
was that we always talk about
percentages of of women that suffer
gender violence we never in it's a
percentage so it's a number that goes
from zero to 100 but we don't really
grasp the the size of the issue cuz
we've never looked at it in terms like
this the first thing that we wanted to
do was make audiences really feel the
sheer number of women that go through
this every year
this is not like sins whatever this is
every year so you're not gonna get to
any content until you're done scrolling
through seventy five thousand women who
suffer gender violence against women
every year we tighten it we timed it so
we designed it and timed it so it was
quick enough for people to actually
reach the content but painful enough to
get you to scroll through those 75,000
little little women and it made sense it
I get got a reaction from from people
the first thing you you find in that
documentary is web documentary is this
is putting this data in more more raw
terms and that is because and it's it's
a more it's a more putting this in
putting it in this more simpler terms in
this more storytelling terms it just
makes sense for me since the very
beginning and it seems like it's it has
worked so far in and the when I was at
the New York Times we started to adopt
this kind of storytelling techniques to
to do data journalism data visualization
it's because we listen and tell stories
from a very young age and it's a very
human tool to for understanding is
perhaps their the most human tool for
cognition storytelling it's our way to
understand the world around us and if we
pair it with with this data-driven and
evidence-based sort of approach I think
you can move our audiences to to act on
on issues thank you very much
so when you scroll down these women to
see to eventually read the article how
do you know what is quick enough or but
also fame painful enough do you do any
kind of you tested with with enough
people around you and you also go by gut
feeling we're not is its is heuristics
it's a shortcut we're not we didn't run
any sort of tests to see what what was
the optimal time to to do it we we just
felt like and the pent also depends on
the on your speed and doing it
we felt like around seven seconds was
was enough to get you mad enough and
thank you so much for a very powerful
presentation I should say thank you and
really impressive visualization my
question is what tools do you use to
create this visualization in depends so
if you think if you think about that
like super fast process that I showed in
the at the beginning very fast video
which I do I did data analysis I do and
I do data presentation for the data
analysis I use most of the times are the
statistical language and if that's not
enough or I don't remember how to do it
in our I build little programs in in
JavaScript in note and if not and for
the for the if it's very simple you can
do it in Google Spreadsheets though and
for the presentation I use d3 mostly for
visualization purposes hi and thanks
again the speech was really great I was
just wondering when you are pitching a
story directly to a publisher of some
kind so the Google Trends example that
you gave do you go through the entire
end-to-end process
by yourself or do you collaborate with
others so on the design side for example
is it completely it depends on the on
the Google Trends story and this is this
is in the context of a larger project
that they're doing there they've
contacted a bunch of visual designers to
come up with stories around data around
their data and see what what things of
interest we can find they had contacted
me a while ago
but I was at the Guardian so I didn't
really have time to do it so when I was
no longer at the garden I said hey so I
thought about this what do you guys
think about it and I work with with
their with the editor of the Google
Trends the director of Google Trends I
know if what's exactly his title Simon
Rogers used to be at the Guardian and I
worked with with an analyst in in his
team and I also worked with Alberto
Cairo who is who's been art directing
some of this things but in this case I
just did it by myself
but some of the things that we did at
the Guardian so at the Guardian we had a
really big group and we were lucky
enough to have I think was like seven
eight ish and developers four of them
were also really talented designers and
two of them were data scientists and
that team would when when a story when
we came up with a story or when a store
or when a story came to to us would
collaborate with with report with more
traditional reporters and with more
traditional designers to come up with
with this with this stories I was just
there to edit them
and clear obstacles for them and be the
bouncing board for their ideas
[Music]